foreign
[Music]
it doesn't matter
ready for lunch
say lunch no I said Lots
foreign
[Music]
look at your paws whoa it's some kind of
Fireball well that makes sense you're a
fire pup I wonder what your power is
huh Chase Marshall up here hey how'd you
get over there so fast get over where
great now the clumsy pup shoots
Fireballs out of his paws
I'm a wrecking
whoa Rubble are you okay
rock and roll
now you three puffballs serious about
joining the PAW Patrol one day yeah
more than anything in the entire
universe I think I'm gonna teach you
everything I know and turn you into Lane
mean fluffy little rescue machines 7 98
99 100 your time
eat
we're still running with the fake guns
now okay
[Music]
on September 29th do you have what it
takes to join the patrols
Paw Patrol the mighty movie rated
Pikachu only in theaters September 29th
when our world is threatened
one team is ready to Launch
does he say lunch uh no I said launch
[Music]
it's giving off some kind of energy
no way this September I think we've got
super powers
and that's why I wear a hard hat
[Music]
look at your paws
now the clumsy pup shoots Fireballs out
of his paws
Heroes superpowers are real hits the big
screen
how about the PAW Patrol but more but
just a little bit extra
how about
the mighty pups
it's supposed to be my superpowers
coming in
I'm gonna take them one by one
oh my goodness I could talk
give me that
it's so fun well well home Dinger he
looks different than I remember
you go up against
you go up against all of us
now that we're super I'm never gonna get
to sleep well you're probably more tired
than you
oh you've got to be kidding me
[Music]
this meteor gave us
super powers
Skye gets super strength and the power
of flight
Chase gains the power of super Steve
there's superpowers are big look at your
paws
awesome dude who won with the water
check me out I'm a walking magnet
sorry about that come on rock and roll
I'm a wrecking ball that's so cool with
Liberty she doesn't have a superpower so
throughout the film you can see you're
constantly trying to find it but yet she
doesn't give up on herself
it's against me it's the PAW Patrol and
a totally different level
it's gonna be crazy get ready for a
super adventure
guys
it's gonna blow you away
oh yeah 29th the PAW Patrol is here
these movies get better each and every
time I'm excited to eat the PAW Patrol
in another life they're on a totally
different level
7 31 p.m immediately suddenly beard of
course
the PAW Patrol crew all have their own
traits that makes each of them special
great now the clumsy pup shoots
Fireballs out of his paw
Tory advanced
she my superpowers she knows what the
power really does so she's trying to get
it back from the Paw Patrol I'm gonna
take them one by one
generation of pups
what's up we're gonna love them because
they're all cute I'm gonna turn you into
lean mean lovely little rescue machines
when they all come together they make a
very powerful team
can you go up against one of us you go
up against all of us just because you're
younger or you're smaller doesn't mean
that you can't make a difference or be
the mightiest pup
foreign
Hello Universe hello Internet my name is
Victoria Vance and I'm making this video
as proof that I'm the greatest scientist
in history oh and don't believe the
rumors I'm not a mad scientist I mean
sure sometimes I act a little mad and I
am a Scientist but that doesn't make me
a mad scientist
[Music]
oh